it's not the best time to be a Russian
sausage Tycoon a Russian military
General the editor of a Russian tabloid
the head of a Russian ski resort a
Russian rail magnet a Russian Shipyard
magnet
or Russian oil and gas Executives on
Christmas Eve Pavel antov reportedly
fell from the third floor window of his
hotel in India he had just celebrated
his 65th birthday besides his success in
the meat processing industry Antonov was
a member of a regional Russian
Parliament he appeared to criticize a
Russian missile attack in a residential
district in Kiev a message from his
WhatsApp account read it's extremely
difficult to call all this anything but
Terror he later claimed that the message
was someone else's not his and
reaffirmed his support of Putin
so many Russian business Executives have
mysteriously died that there is an
entire Wikipedia page dedicated to them
the number of dead reached 25 by the end
of 2022 oil executive Alexander sabwatin
was allegedly Poisoned With toad Venom
in the home of a shaman to better
understand what's going on I spoke with
an authority figure on Russia so I want
to ask you if you believe that the
Kremlin is behind them all or if the
answer is more complicated it's
surprisingly enough more complicated to
be honest look the Kremlin on the whole
does not need to kill people
the Kremlin has so many other ways that
it can threaten and intimidate and if
need be in prison Mark galiadi is a
professor at University College London
who recently released his book hooton's
Wars I think instead what we're seeing
is in part genuine cases of accidents
and suicides particularly for people who
have suddenly lost their their
Lifestyles their business Empires and so
forth but also a Resurgence of something
that we saw in the 1990s which is in
some ways murder as a business tactic
Russia was in political and economic
turmoil following the collapse of the
Soviet Union in 1991. violence as a way
of doing business was the norm what we
could see is a lot of clashes rivalries
over suddenly available markets and so
forth and at that time absolutely you
know we saw a whole Spate of killings
Vladimir Putin was credited as a leader
who restored stability in the 2000s and
2010s
however following Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and the crush of Western
sanctions galliadi believes the
Cutthroat way of doing business is back
all of a sudden shall I say the cake is
shrinking quite a dramatic pace and
therefore this is what's happening we're
seeing a Resurgence of a lot of the bad
old ways in which actually all of a
sudden people are competing that much
more fiercely
for controller companies controller
resources controls of markets I don't
think this is the kind of sinister plot
by by the Kremlin another Russian expert
I spoke with came to the same conclusion
Peter Rutland is a professor of
government at Wesleyan University in
Connecticut the sanctions that the West
imposed on Russia the freezing of bank
accounts the seizure of some foreign
assets over a thousand individuals have
been put on sanctions lists by Western
governments so that's made the lives of
Russian business people very difficult
very stressful in a country with a third
highest suicide mortality rate in the
world he says it's highly probable that
some of the tycoons took their own lives
to be clear the Kremlin does kill when
it wants to in 2006 Alexander lit
venenko a former Russian intelligence
agent who defected was poisoned with a
cup of tea containing the radioactive
compound polonium at a hotel in London
Russia is the only country that produces
polonium the conclusion that the Russian
state was probably involved in the
murder of Mr lipvinyenko is deeply
disturbing
litvinenko's story has now been
dramatized in a mini-series the man who
says I must die I know this person you
have an eye his name is Vladimir Putin
there's been a long history of
poisonings linked to the Kremlin jailed
opposition leader Alexei navalny who was
nearly killed by a nerve agent in 2020.
investigative journalist Anna
polikovskaya a vocal Putin critic was
poisoned on a flight but survived two
years later she was shot and killed in
her apartment elevator on Putin's
birthday however these political targets
are unlike the recent deaths involving
corporate Executives business people
frankly you know if they want to get rid
of them they can just arrest them it's a
lot easier so as easy as it may seem to
point the finger at the Kremlin the
bigger picture is more complicated
nonetheless the deaths are very
suspicious some even involve entire
families Sergey pratasinia the former
deputy head of Russia's second largest
gas company was accused of killing his
wife and daughter at their Spanish villa
with an ax before hanging himself
however his former employer novitec said
speculations about his death bear no
relation to reality this was backed up
by Sergey son who was not in Spain at
the time he told the UK's Daily Mail he
loved my mother and especially Maria my
sister she was his princess he could
never do anything to harm them I don't
know what happened that night but I know
that my dad did not hurt them if the
death toll continues in 2023 speculation
over their cause will remain strong as
former Soviet defense minister Jorge
zukov once said there are things in
Russia which are not as they seem
with the war in Ukraine Independent
Media Outlets have been shut down in
Russia many have tried to browse foreign
media for news to help you browse
quickly and securely online I recommend
guardio guardio is an extension that
protects your information while you're
browsing it's kind of like having an
online bodyguard that sits in your
browser cardio blocks a hundred times
more harmful websites and phishing
attempts than its competitors Guardia
will block dangerous downloads even if
you've clicked download to ensure no
harm goes to your computer
you know those annoying pop-up ads they
may indicate that you have malware on
your device guardio traces the sources
and eliminates the invasive
notifications all at once you can
install guardio from the Chrome or Edge
store as I did after installing a free
security scan will detect existing
threats found on your computer you can
then get a free 7-Day trial to remove
these threats enable real-time
production and get real-time alerts when
your information could be at risk if
you'd like to protect yourself and your
family from these emerging online
threats you can start your free trial by
clicking my custom link in the
description guard dot IO slash newsthink
guard.io news think and get 20 off your
monthly subscription which is good for
five family members at no extra cost